talk to me about working on something
like this man I mean you got some of the
creators behind Ted lasso is is it does
it raise the stakes for you does it add
pressure
doesn't add pressure but it actually
adds confidence because you have people
who are the best at what they do and I'm
a huge uh Bill Lawrence fan and Brett
Goldstein I think he's a genius so to
kind of uh join forces I just felt I
felt really lucky
it gives us like a behind the scenes
look at therapists um what was your take
before coming onto the series about
therapy and did it change afterwards
well what it made me realize is it's
very easy to get stuck in a rut and even
therapy you can go in and just wax
poetic about your problems week after
week and not have them change so
um this sort of radical approach of like
I'm just going to tell these people what
to do am I border on unethical but uh it
gets results sometimes sometimes kids
sometimes bad yeah I love it it's so
refreshing from a guy who's you know
done his share therapy it's so
refreshing um let's talk Harrison Ford
for a second icon on set is it a pinch
me moment for you what's it like you
guys together blow up the TV stream like
you you thanks a lot yeah it's a dream
you make an offer to someone like
Harrison Ford assuming he's going to say
no but for a week you get to like say
you've offered it to Harrison Ford and
then he said yes and then you're
scrambling like holy you know what
Harrison Ford's going to show up here uh
but yeah he um he treated all of us like
a peer he broke through the awe really
quickly and he was here to make art and
we did our best
incredible to hear what what surprised
you about Harrison the most
you know I was just shocked every day by
his generosity not that I didn't expect
it but he really was so so kind to me
and uh and the show I desperately want
his approval you can imagine in life I
desperately wanted his approval and he
he gave it it was in doses but he gave
it
um I love that so much I'm gonna let you
get out here in a second I want to talk
real quick 15 years since Forgetting
Sarah Marshall
dude give me a memory what do you what
give me a good thought something you
remember from that sale
my my main memory uh is that Jack
McBrayer was only scheduled to work for
a few days but somehow managed to stay
in Hawaii for like all 16 weeks of the
shoot we would just see him getting
Tanner and Tanner every day
I love that so much dude congrats on the
show congrats on everything
um Neil Patrick Harris just had a cameo
oh
foreign
[Music]
what did you think of that and can we
get you to Cameo at any point
uh I didn't know about that but those
people changed my life and I would do
anything they ever asked me to dude
you're the absolute best congrats on
this series man I hope you do 100
seasons of it because we all need it
thanks I'd be so old by then all right
all right okay all right thank you
[Music]